just because it feels uncomfortable
doesn't mean it's not good
i think so often not only on film but
in life
we so want to feel comfortable but that
doesn't always bring the best results if
i look back i think some of my more
successful things and my point of view
have been the things i've been most
nervous about and probably most unsure
when i began
there's something about jumping off that
cliff which
means you end up going for broke and
probably end up taking a few more risks
if you know what i mean where you want
to get to in life is never as important
as the way you want to live your life
you suffer from a bit of anxiety when
you're in front of the camera
but that you name your your confident
personality frank yeah oh my god and
your and your and your anxious
personality child what happened to me in
film was it was random it would appear
sometimes and that was something i'd
never encounter i understand if you're
scared of heights you always getting
heights but some days i'll be fine and
then some days i would just get nervous
and get in my head so
uh
i don't know if you guys know uh anthony
robbins you know the motivational
motivational dude yeah yeah i mean he
does motivate her he's not really a
motivational guy actually he's really
quite brilliant in breaking down how we
think the patterns of behavior we have
and so i met him we were mates i never
went to him to i never went to one of
his workshops we were just friends and i
rang i said mate i want to come to you
professionally i need to ask you a
question he said to me what the biggest
mistake people make with fear
is saying i'm scared i hate this get it
out i don't want you in my life this is
not helping me and you get
obviously really wound up so he said
you've got to remember the times where
you feel confident name that character
so that feels scared and as you're
walking on a set realize that the fear
is good
that it got you where you are that it
makes you work the fear sometimes
actually goes oh i better work really
hard on this film so he said that for
you embrace it work really hard and then
on that day when you walk on set
charles thanks
but i don't need you right now and then
be frank when the things most matter
you're so desperately don't want to
destroy it for being scared that you can
really destroy it
when i hosted the oscars i was i was
like wow man this is a billion people
and i just thought okay
whatever you do just remember you're a
kid from moronga in sydney you're
hosting the oscars have some fun you
know and luckily for me those turning
points
i've somehow always stuck to that idea
of just having fun i genuinely like to
be friendly with everyone in the
australian film industry everyone talks
to everyone and if they're not making
fun of you then they really don't like
you so there's a problem and i also when
i first went to america i noticed there
was an unspoken it's not people tell
stories of don't look this actor in the
eye and all that i've never heard that
before but there is a slightly unwritten
rule of leave the actor alone
let them do their thing
it could be a right process it could be
because their style i'm not sure and i
always try literally on the first day to
break that down because i feel
self-conscious in that environment i'd
much prefer a grip
you know making fun of me than calling
me mr jackman and
then i say nothing until they say thank
you it's been great working with you you
know i much prefer to feel we're in it
together because
i i didn't come into this business my
first job was 26 i did not come in fully
formed i always feel that i'm a work in
progress and there is no absolutely i
promise you no way i would be standing
on the stage with this extraordinary
honor
if it wasn't for the many many people um
and i know it's easy and you hear people
all the time thanking their team
their agents and it always feels like
perfunctory well when i came to
hollywood
i was about 30 years old i wasn't a kid
i felt i understood people a little bit
i had no idea really i met a thousand
people
and
three of those people
i met are still with me today 15 years
later and i my whole approach
to meeting them and trying to decide who
i was going to work with was the aussie
good bloke rule because i had no idea if
anyone could do their job i mean
everyone seemed great to me so i just
applies if they seem like a good bloke
if they seem like they're true to the
word if they seem like they're genuine
then i'm gonna go with it raising five
children alone there must have been some
system of organization now i find it
hard to believe how well organized it
was it was chores written up we had
chore sheets so
five kids five work days to the week the
weekends were a little different but
so once a week you would
your job would be the dishwasher
once a week would be dinner so you cook
dinner once a week would be the lunches
once a week would be the washing
monday nights would be the communal
clearing of the clean washing on the
table it
saturday mornings we had chores
uh sundays was always dad observed the
sabbath so we had to go to
sunday school and then we had sunday
lunch
it was it was very very organized and
from age eight i was doing my own
washing
ironing my own clothes
i mean i'm sure there's other kids who
did it but
to me it was normal uh
to this day if someone cooks for me i
automatically get up to clean because if
you cook you don't clean
if you clean you don't cook and that all
these things that i learned from my dad
and it was just
survival for him you know he had five
kids and a full-time job everyone had to
pitch in and do something he had five
kids a full-time job and he traveled
yeah he traveled uh
i think i started acting to try and work
myself out i i don't think i ever
thought about becoming an actor i
stumbled into an acting class and i
remember thinking everyone should do
this this is kind of the breathing the
learning to just let go of yourself have
fun learning to trust your instincts and
not be afraid of what other people think
about that this is these are tools for
life i probably thought that was going
to be the end of it this is like a
that's like a good self-help class you
know
um and i was
probably 26 before i got my first job so
it took me a while i was a slow learner
well in general when i was younger
everything
i can be critical of myself just
mattered too much i mean not just acting
i can look back now and go come on you
know it was it was a game of cricket it
wasn't the end of the world but at the
time it felt like that and i think
at the beginning of my career it all
felt like that if i didn't get a gig or
if the gig didn't go well or the other
thing for me has been
choices making choices i've i
learnt
the hard way sometimes doing things that
i didn't feel were right went against my
gut on it that's hard and i do i really
try to avoid that now even and and
actually failure if you really believe
in it when you say yes it's fine i'm
with you if you know why you did things
right
and you're kind of pure and you're
in that you can live with
whatever the outcome is yeah because you
can't control everything right so you
can only control your intention and your
kind of
yeah your good impulse your your
uh degree of engagement when you're free
of the idea of the result sometimes the
engagement can run so much deeper you
know because you're not preoccupied and
thinking ahead you're not getting ahead
of yourself you're doing this for this
it's a surreal experience i'm a kid
from a suburb called warunga in the
northern suburbs of sydney i have so
many people to thank
i am incredibly incredibly grateful you
believed in me when i couldn't
you've loved me
with a passion and a depth
that i didn't even know existed
and i don't think i even felt that i
deserved
you have pushed and encouraged me
[Music]
when
i was scared to venture out
you have smiled me the smiling
you have sung me into singing you have
loved me into loving and like everything
i do in my life i share this with you i
love you
thank you all
[Music]